i also have to ask you about a certain
something you posted on your twitter
account because i kind of love
this possibility hercules have you heard
anything about the song you did
you know what that wasn't as planned as
it seems
i actually during the beginning of
quarantine especially
was playing so much piano my childhood
piano that i got
shipped out to la and i was just going
through all the catalogs and i was
laying down a lot and posting a lot
and also not posting a lot so that was
something that i actually just had on my
camera roll that i
only sent to my family uh because my mom
loves when i just sing in the rafters
and um and then so when i saw that i was
like oh i actually conveniently have
this and so people are like skylar aston
auditions for hercules the thing is
if i was auditioning for the role of
hercules i would act it more
i probably wouldn't be playing my own
piano and i probably wouldn't choose the
michael bolton key which is
literally in the sky um i think the
in the key that roger bart sings it in
the movie it's a lot lower more
manageable
and uh a a little bit more of an i want
song
so when the time comes if the time comes
i'm ready to train i'm ready to prepare
and i'm ready to give everything i can
to hercules if possible if not hercules
i might suggest
looking at robin hood too i feel like
you i don't know i still can't picture
what exactly is going to happen with
that one but i still feel like
your skill set would very well suit that
role talk to
those producers my agents and my mom who
will agree with you